here with reaction senate judiciary
committee chairman lindsey graham
senator let's start with the sub source
because the sub source was interviewed
correct me if i'm wrong three days in
january of 2017. am i correct on that
that's right yes and actually again in
march on two or three separate occasions
three days in january again in march of
2017.
okay so the sub source now this is the
guy that said this is bar
talk and didn't the mueller report say
weren't we
told that this information had russian
connections
when in fact it did not have any russian
connections whatsoever
i don't know about you but always assume
the russian sub-source was some guy in
russia
deep in the bowels of the kremlin
feeding this stuff
to christopher steele the sub-source
was a senior russian researcher at the
brookings institute
and an employee of christopher steele
living in the united states
he calls up a bunch of people in russia
where do you think this information came
from
it came from the russian intelligence
service they played this guy like a
fiddle
this was russian disinformation some fbi
agent recognized it as such
he told steele here's what i found but
it's not really reliable be cautious
still turned it into a tom clancy novel
the fbi bought it hook line and sinker
and got warrants with it
the most successful political operation
in the history of the democratic party
because still was on the payroll of the
uh democratic party and hillary clinton
so so they were warned now we learned in
the
unclassified document from last week
from you what did we learn
right we learned that when they went to
first brief the president national
security adviser
elect that would be if in fact they got
elected uh
general flynn uh that was all the ruse
for operation crossfire hurricane and
we know that they knew before the first
30 dossier
that that it was a dirty dossier was
unverified steele had an agenda clinton
paid for it
they said it was verified it's
unverifiable it's now been debunked
they still signed those two and then
even after the sub source
in other words christopher seals steal
sources
then they went on to sign two more
warrants now
right how is that not premeditated fraud
on a fisa court
and what has taken john durham so long
to get to that fundamental conclusion
because what we now know is overwhelming
incontrovertible slam dunk
that now beats needs to be brought
before a grand jury lindsey graham
when's that going to happen
yeah i don't know you'll uh we'll find
out soon i suppose but i'm going to uh
interview the intel analyst who uh
interviewed the russian sub source
and produced a 40-page memo if nobody
else will talk to him i'm going to talk
to
him and the case agent and ask him a
simple question when you found out that
the russian sub-source was a still
employee
not based in russia but based in the
united states and everything in the
document was bar talk hearsay in garbage
did you tell anybody and i guarantee you
they did but here's what else you're
going to find
this week i hope the congress got
suspicious about the sub source
wanted to know how reliable the person
was and in 2018
2018 asked for a briefing from the fbi
about the russian subsource
because the intel committees were
getting suspicious and i found the
briefing notes and they lied to congress
the fbi did like they lied to the fisa
court what we have over a three year
period
16 17 and 18 is a complete
breakdown of the rule of law
manipulation of the system at every turn
and it's just not a few bad actors
unfortunately this is system failure
and so you will have sally yates
tomorrow you plan on bringing in comey
immediately
at some point struck in page at some
point yeah do we ever get to the july
5th meeting in the oval office where
biden talked about the logan act and
obama talked about getting his people on
this his people are the right people and
when sally yates admitted she was
shocked that
obama knew all about the kislyak call
and comey was there and comey's even
saying we have nothing and now we know
peter strzok said we have nothing with
any evidence of trump-russia collusion
and they knew it all and they kept going
forward with the lies to the fisa court
and then they went forward with an
impeachment investigation
i want to know what they knew and when
they knew it are they all going to be
held accountable lindsey graham
well all i can tell you is that we're
going to have an election in 2020 and i
hope people will consider the obama
justice department to be the sewer that
it was
but sally yates will testify for the
judiciary committee august the 5th
and we'll have a talk after school she
signed one of the warrants didn't she
senator
yeah maybe one of the questions i asked
her if you knew then what you know now
would you have signed it
well rod rosenstein answered that
question before your committee recently
and he said he would not
let's see what sally yates says tomorrow
keep staying keep up the good work
we will hold them accountable